en este vídeo y tal vez en los
posteriores quiero hablarles acerca de
todo lo que ya hemos visto es decir
quiero contar todo lo que hemos visto
acerca del vector columna linealmente
independiente es un espacio vectorial
una base un espacio vectorial el espacio
en una matriz del espacio 9 una matriz
en su forma escalonada
todo eso lo quiero meter en un vídeo o
en varios a partir de ahorita así que
aquí tengo una matriz y lo que quiero es
investigar qué onda con esta matriz y lo
primero que me gustaría ver es cuál es
el espacio columna de la matriz ha hecho
déjame ponerlo aquí abajo el espacio
columna de la matriz
y si haces un poco de memoria lo que
vimos en el vídeo pasado es que el
espacio columna de la matriz ar es
exactamente lo mismo que el espacio
vectorial generado por los vectores
columnas la matriz
es decir el vector 123 el vector 114 el
vector 141 y el vector 132 es decir me
estoy tomando todos los vectores columna
de esta matriz am y lo que voy a hacer
es calcular el espacio vectorial de esta
matriz y este
es el espacio columna y si a mí me
impidieran cuál es el espacio columna
pues ya cabe es justo el espacio
vectorial que se forma por estos cuatro
vectores pero saber si son linealmente
independientes si son una base que
genere en el espacio y cómo se podrá
visualizar el espacio al que me estoy
refiriendo esas son preguntas que voy a
tratar de resolver a lo largo de este
vídeo pero lo que sí quiero que quede
claro es que si a ti te preguntaban cuál
es el espacio columna de la matriz a
pues es justo esto que tenemos aquí el
espacio vectorial formado por estos
cuatro vectores y ya esa es la respuesta
ahora bien si yo quisiera saber si estos
cuatro vectores son linealmente
independientes o dependientes pues una
de las maneras para resolver esta
pregunta es fijarme el espacio nulo de
la matriz a pero recuerda que el espacio
mundo de la matriz am y esto fue lo que
vimos hace un par de vídeos es
exactamente el mismo que el espacio nulo
de la forma escalonada de la matriz y
por lo tanto si buscamos el espacio nulo
de la forma escalonada de la matriz am
creo que va a ser mucho más sencillo
para encontrar el espacio nulo de la
matriz a y recuerda si el espacio es
nulo de la matriz am solamente contiene
al vector
entonces mis vectores que forman a mi
espacio columna son linealmente
independientes si existe al menos otro
vector que no sea el vector cero en un
espacio nulo de la matriz a entonces
estos vectores son linealmente
dependientes así que para hacer las
cosas más fácil primero busquemos la
forma escalonada de la matriz am y voy a
dejar el primer renglón igual y a
continuación lo que quiero hacer es que
tengamos un cero en este primer
componente es decir voy a multiplicar
por dos la primera fila ya esto le voy a
restar la segunda fila y que me queda y
para que no se nos olvide que estamos
haciendo déjeme escribirlo aquí lo que
voy a hacer es tomarme dos veces este
renglón y después restarle la fila
número dos y bueno entonces que me va a
quedar 2 por 12 menos 12 0 después 2 por
12 menos uno me va a dar 1 después 2 por
12 menos 4 estos menos 22 menos 4 - 2 y
por último dos por 12 menos tres es
menos
2 3 - 1 y ya tengo este otro renglón que
tengo aquí y ahora lo que voy a hacer es
fijarme del tercer renglón y me voy a
tomar este tercer renglón menos tres
veces el primero lo que voy a intentar
es que tengamos la menor cantidad de
entradas negativas por lo tanto no voy a
tomar esta tercera columna menos tres
veces la primera columna para que en un
principio me quede cero y que me va a
quedar así que esto menos esto déjame
ponerlo aquí lo voy a escribir son tres
veces esta columna y me voy a tomar la
resta de esta menos esta y entonces que
me va a quedar 3 menos 304 menos 3 es
uno que te das cuenta que hay puros 34
menos 3 es 11 menos 3 - 2 y 2 - 3 - 1 y
bueno ya que tengo ahora a esta matriz
de aquí lo que voy a hacer en primer
lugar es fijarme en estos dos unos que
tengo aquí y dos voy a reducir para que
poco a poco me quede una matriz
escalonada entonces el segundo renglón
lo voy a dejar tal cual cero
1 2 - 1 y voy a trabajar cuando el
primer renglón y con el tercer renglón y
para el primer renglón de que voy a
hacer es tomarme el renglón 1 la fila 1
- la fila 2 es decir este menos este 1 -
0 1 1 1 es 01 - menos 2 es lo mismo que
uno más 2 que es 3 103 y por último y
después
1 - menos uno en lo cuales dos uno más
uno es 2 1 032 y aquí abajo en mi tercer
renglón en mi tercer fila date cuenta de
lo siguiente que tenemos dos filas
iguales y por lo tanto puedo eliminarlas
si yo restó la segunda menos la tercera
entonces se va a cancelar la tercera y
me va a quedar como las dos son iguales
cuando yo tomé la diferencia de ambas
pues no va a quedar por 000 menos dos
más dos es cero y menos uno más uno es 0
x 0 y aquí también 0 menos uno más uno
es cero y bueno ya que tengo la forma
escalonada de la matriz
esta es la forma escalonada
porque en mi tercer renglón es un
renglón de puros ceros y los dos
primeros renglones las dos primeras
filas están escalonadas y por lo tanto
estábamos buscando el espacio nulo de la
matriz am dijimos que el espacio nulo de
la matriz a es exactamente lo mismo que
el espacio nulo de la forma escalonada
de la matriz a que es justo esta que
tengo aquí y como encuentro un espacio
nulo bueno para esto lo que tenemos que
hacer es tomarnos a esta matriz y
multiplicarla por un vector de cuatro
componentes porque tenemos cuatro
columnas x 1 x 2 x 3 de x 4 y el espacio
nulo es todos los vectores x de esta
forma que cumplan que a x o en este caso
la forma escalonada de la matriz a por x
sea igual al vector 0 el vector 0 de 3
componentes porque tenemos 3 filas y
bueno si te das cuenta aquí lo que puedo
hacer es un sistema de ecuaciones en los
cuales voy a obtener variables pivote y
variables libres las variables pivotes
son aquellas que si nos fijamos en su
respectiva fila en la forma escalonada
de la matriz a tenemos una entrada con 1
y las otras dos entradas puros ceros
mientras que las variables libres van a
ser nuestras variables dependientes es
como variables independientes y
variables dependientes así que fíjate
bien vamos a multiplicar esta primera
fila por nuestro vector xy me queda 1
por x 1 que ese es uno más 0 por x 2 que
esté x 2 + 3 por x 3 que es 3 veces x 3
más 2 por x 4 que es 2 veces x 4 y esto
tiene que ser igual a 0 a este 0 que
está en nuestro primer componente de
nuestro vector resultante 0 ahora mi
siguiente ecuación quién va a ser pues
es esta segunda fila por mi vector x y
es 0 x x 1 + 1 por x 2 es decir x 2
menos 2 veces x 3 - x 4 y esto también
tiene que ser igual a 0 y si
multiplicamos nuestra tercera fila por
el vector x pues date cuenta que no
llegamos a nada porque tendremos 0 + 000
es igual a 0 y pues eso pues ya no
sabemos por lo tanto no tenemos una
tercera cuestión solamente tenemos estas
dos ecuaciones las cuales cada una de
ellas tiene una variable pivote
qué es estas dos que estoy circulando
aquí y tiene aparte variables libres o
variables independientes y las variables
vivo te las voy a dejar del lado
izquierdo de la ecuación mientras que
mis variables libres las voy a poner del
lado derecho de la ecuación date cuenta
que encontramos una variable pivote
porque si nos fijamos en la fila que
tiene la variable pivote
todas las demás entradas de esa fila son
cero mientras que una variable es libre
cuando existe el menos otra componente
en esa fila que no es cero por lo tanto
x 3 es una variable libre x 4 es una
variable libre mientras que que es 1 y
x2 son variables pivote y bueno pues voy
a despejar las a ver qué es lo que me
queda
y tengo x 1 es igual a todo esto
entonces vamos a dejar a x 1 del lado
izquierda de la ecuación y vamos a pasar
todo lo que no tenga que ver con x 1 del
lado derecho estos dos se van porque es
0 x x 20 x 1 x 0 0 y me queda que x 1 en
la primera ecuación es igual a menos 3
veces x 3 menos 2 veces x 4 lo único que
hice fue restar menos 3 veces x 3 menos
2 veces x 4 de ambos lados de la
ecuación
y de la segunda ecuación que obtengo x2
es igual a 2 veces x 3 + x 41 que está
siendo sumando 2 veces x 3 más x 4
de ambos lados de la ecuación y aquí te
das cuenta que ya tengo dos variables
pivote o dos variables dependientes que
es x1 y x2 mientras tengo dos variables
independientes o libres que es x 3 y x 4
y ahora sí vamos a escribir entonces
quién es el espacio en uno de la matriz
a que por ciento es el espacio no lo de
la forma escalonada de la matriz y lo
podemos ver como los siguientes vectores
los vectores x 1 x 2 x 3 x 4 que cumplan
y aquí es cuando voy a utilizar esta
información que tengo esta información
de mis variables pivote y de mis
variables libres porque hay x1 lo puedo
ver como menos 3 veces x 3 menos 2 veces
x 4 y x2 lo puedo ver también como 2
veces x 3 más x 4
es decir que x1 y x2 dependen de x 3 y
de x 4 por lo tanto si yo quiero
escribir al vector x1 y x2 x
x4 entonces lo puedo ver de la siguiente
manera como x1 lo puedo escribir
dependiendo x3 y x4 y como x 2 también
lo puedo escribir dependiendo x 3 y x 4
entonces a mi vector x lo puedo ver como
a x 3 que por cierto va a ser una
constante que multiplica a un cierto
vector y después como todo también está
escrito en la variable x 4
voy a poner más x 4 que multiplica a
otro vector x 3 a que vector multiplica
pues bueno fíjate que forma x 1 con
menos 3 veces x 3 menos 2 veces x 4 por
lo tanto voy a poner aquí en el vector
de este lado del x 3 en menos 3 ya esto
hay que sumarle menos 2 veces x 4 así
que aquí voy a poner menos 3 menos 3 x x
3 - 2 x x 4 me dan y vector x 1 se
cumple la igualdad y x2 se forma con 2
veces x 3 +
una vez x 4 2 veces x 3 + x 4
es lo mismo que x 2 se cumple mi
igualdad y después x 3 es igual a x 3 lo
multiplicamos por 1 y le sumamos 0 veces
x 4
x4 lo podemos ver como 0 veces x 3 + una
vez el mismo una vez x 4 es por eso la
importancia de variables libres y
variables pivote porque las variables
libres se pueden escribir como
combinación lineal de ellas mismas
mientras que las variables pivote
también se pueden escribir como una
combinación lineal de las variables
libres y entonces obtengo que el vector
x 1 x 2 x 3 x 4 lo podemos ver como esta
combinación lineal de estos dos vectores
porque tanto x 3 x 4 existen en los
números reales como habíamos visto hace
un par de vídeos entonces a este vector
que tengo aquí lo puedo ver como una
combinación lineal de estos dos vectores
del vector -3 2 1 y 0 y del vector menos
2 1 0 y 1 estos dos vectores cuando
tomamos cualquier combinación lineal de
ellos nos va a cumplir mi ecuación
homogénea asociada y por lo tanto puedo
decir que como toda combinación lineal
de estos vectores nos sirven para
resolver la ecuación homogénea asociada
entonces el espacio vectorial formado
por estos dos vectores es exactamente el
mismo que el espacio nulo de la matriz
y por lo tanto es lo mismo que el
espacio nulo de la forma escalonada de
la matriz am así que ya tenemos una
respuesta el espacio nulo de la matriz
am es el espacio vectorial generado por
estos dos vectores por el vector menos 3
2 10 y por el vector menos 2 10 y 1 y
entonces nos ponemos bastante feliz por
esta respuesta pero pero que eso que
queríamos realmente entonces vamos a
recordar atrás lo que íbamos lo que
íbamos era buscar el espacio nulo de la
matriz a que por 7 habíamos dicho que es
lo mismo que el espacio un nudo de la
forma escalonada de la matriz ham porque
nosotros queríamos saber qué pasaba con
los siguientes vectores con el vector
132 los vectores columnas de la matriz a
123 perdón el vector 123 el vector 114
el vector 141 y el vector 132 y el
vector 132 y tras lo que andábamos era
respondernos la pregunta acerca de que
estos vectores serán linealmente
independientes o linealmente
dependientes así que déjame ponerlo aquí
estos vectores son linealmente
independientes
esa era nuestra pregunta recuerdas y
bueno pues vamos a ver un poco de la
teoría que vimos en el vídeo pasado
nosotros habíamos dicho ya habíamos
concluido en el vídeo pasado que si
nosotros teníamos los vectores del
espacio columna de la matriz am estos
vectores eran linealmente independientes
si encontrábamos una única solución a la
ecuación línea la homogénea asociada a x
igual a cero si solamente teníamos una
solución a esta ecuación estábamos
diciendo entonces que la solución era el
vector x igual a cero y por lo tanto que
el espacio nulo de la matriz am sólo
contenía el vector cero el espacio en
uno de la matriz a solamente contenía el
vector cero y por lo tanto eran
linealmente independientes además
habíamos visto que todo esto eran un sí
solos y por lo tanto si yo encuentro al
menos otro vector que no sea el vector
cero en un espacio nulo de la matriz am
esto quiere decir que en mis vectores
son linealmente dependientes recuerda
que en cualquier otro caso que no pasará
esto que se cumple aquí abajo entonces
tenía dependencia lineal y si te das
cuenta que encontré dos vectores que
están en espacios nulo de la matriz am
estos dos que tengo aquí de hecho
encontré que el espacio vectorial
generado por estos dos era el espacio
nulo de mi matriz amp por lo tanto como
un espacio nulo de mi matriz a contiene
a estos dos vectores de todas sus
combinaciones lineales y no solamente
contiene el cero podemos decir que hay
muchos más vectores que cumplen la
ecuación en línea la homogénea asociada
y entonces esto quiere decir que existen
más de una solución más que solamente el
vector cero y entonces que mis lectores
son linealmente dependientes inspectores
son linealmente dependientes que
responde la pregunta que teníamos en un
inicio saber si el conjunto de vectores
columna de mi espacio columna este
conjunto cda eran linealmente
dependientes o linealmente
independientes y ya podemos construir
que son linealmente dependientes pero
bueno que significa que tenga vectores
linealmente dependientes nosotros nos
tomamos a este espacio vectorial
generado
estos cuatro vectores y si te das cuenta
lo que nos preguntábamos en un inicio es
que si estos cuatro vectores formaban
una base de nuestro espacio y las
respuestas que no forman una base de
nuestro espacio porque no son
linealmente independientes por lo tanto
no es una base de cde a podemos notar
que claramente estos cuatro vectores
generan nuestro sub espacio pero
nosotros linealmente independientes por
lo tanto no son una base de sda y
recuerda que para hacer una base
necesitábamos que fueran linealmente
independientes y que generarán su
espacio oa mi espacio y como no son
linealmente independientes entonces
existe un intruso
supongamos este puede ser cualquiera de
todos los demás tal que no aportan
ninguna nueva información es decir que
podemos escribir a este intruso como una
combinación lineal de los otros tres y
de hecho pues vamos a hacerlo para
acabar todo este análisis así que manos
a la obra y bueno de hecho podría acabar
aquí el vídeo pero no de una vez vamos a
trabajar con todo esto porque me parece
bastante interesante que sabemos
yo sé que x 1 que multiplica a mi primer
vector columna 1 2
+ x2 que multiplica a mi vector 114 más
x 3 que multiplica a mi vector 141 más x
4 que multiplica a 1000 vector
132 esto es igual a 0 porque cumple la
ecuación homogénea y ahora como x 3 y x
4 son variables libres mientras que x1 y
x2 son variables pivote entonces lo que
voy a hacer es darle valores a estas
variables libres es más lo que voy a
hacer es fijarme en esto que tengo aquí
pasar a x 4 del otro lado ya x 3 lo voy
a bautizar con el valor de 0 de una vez
para que se cancele y entonces voy a
pasar a x 4 del otro lado de la ecuación
restando y por lo tanto que me va a
quedar si supongo que x 3 es igual a 0 y
déjame ponerlo aquí como x 3 es una
variable libre es decir es una variable
independiente pues voy a suponer que x 3
es igual a 0 entonces si x 3 es igual a
0 y si paso todo lo que tiene que ver
con x 4
es decir x 4 x el vector 132 del otro
lado de la ecuación entonces que me va a
quedar pues esto se va a ver como x 1
que multiplica el vector 1
+ x2 que multiplica al vector 114
después ya no pongo nada de x 3 porque x
3 es igual a cero y 0 por lo que sea es
0 entonces estos se cancelan se van y
solamente me queda del otro lado de la
ecuación menos x 4 que multiplica al
vector 132 al vector 132 pero bueno x 4
también es una variable libre por lo
tanto voy a suponer que x 4 es igual a
menos 1 x 4 es igual a menos 1 y por lo
tanto menos 1 x menos me va a dar 1
positivo 1 positivo por x 4 pues es 1
todo esto es 1 y me queda 1 por el
vector 132 así que x 1 por el vector 123
+ x2 por el vector 114 tiene que ser
igual al vector 132 ya vamos
simplificando un poco todo esto ojo
cuando x 3 vale 0 y cuando x 4 vale
menos 1 pero está genial porque si que
es 3 vale 0 y x 4 vale menos 1 ya
podemos obtener el valor de x1 y x2 con
estas dos ecuaciones que tengo aquí y
que habíamos encontrado hace rato te das
cuenta entonces déjame
y pegar esto de aquí y las voy a poner
aquí abajo porque voy a trabajar con
ellas dice x1 aquí las voy a poner
es igual a menos 3 veces x 3 menos 2
veces x 4 pero si x 3 vale 0 y x 4 vale
menos 1 entonces x 1 debe de valer menos
2 x menos 1 porque esto se extrae se van
y después me queda menos 2 x menos 1 lo
cual es 2 positivo entonces x 1 va a
valer 2 vamos a escribirlo aquí estos
dos valores implican que x1 marga 2 y
que x 2 cuanto va a valer pues 2 veces x
3 se van y después me queda x 4 pero x 4
vale menos 1 entonces x 2 vale también
menos 1 y entonces ya no puedo
reemplazar aquí x 1 vale 2 x 2 vale
menos 1 y si te das cuenta ya cumple con
que este cuarto vector que yo tengo aquí
este cuarto vector columna lo puedo
representar como una combinación lineal
de estos 2 2 por uno menos uno es 12 por
24 menos 1 es 32 por 36 menos 4 estos ya
se cumplen acabo de encontrar que el
cuarto vector lo puedo escribir como una
combinación lineal
de los dos primeros por lo tanto lo que
me está diciendo es que el cuarto vector
no me dan ninguna información nueva y es
justo por esto que entonces muy conjunto
de vectores no son linealmente
independientes como tengo a x 3 y a x 4
como variables libres entonces dándole
un valor x 3 x 4 encontré que este
vector no me aporta información nueva y
por lo tanto lo puedo escribir como una
combinación de los dos primeros y se
podrá hacer lo mismo con el tercero pues
creo que va a pasar algo parecido así
que vamos a hacerlo de una vez para no
quedarnos con la duda si me fijo en el
tercero pues ahora qué te parece si
agarramos al revés los valores y ahora
digo que x 4 es cero para que estos se
cancelen y x3 es igual a menos uno
entonces si x 4 es 0 déjame ponerlo aquí
entonces esta parte de aquí se va a ir
entonces esta última expresión se vamos
se cancela porque son multiplicando por
cero y si x 3 es igual a menos 1
entonces esto me queda menos 1 aquí en
lugar de x 3 voy a poner menos 1 y si yo
lo paso del otro lado sumando me va a
quedar que x 1 que multiplica el vector
1 2
+ x2 que multiplica el vector 114 esta
suma de estos dos vectores es igual a
este vector pero ya con signo positivo
porque lo estoy pasando el otro lado de
la igualdad entonces se convierte en el
vector 141 positivo y de igual manera ya
tengo un valor para x 4 ya tengo un
valor para x 3 entonces con estas
variables libres puedo reemplazarlas en
estas ecuaciones encontrar mis variables
pivote x1 tiene que ser igual a tres
menos tres por menos uno estrés y x2
tiene que ser igual a menos dos porque
recuerda que todo lo que tienen que ver
con x 4 se va se cancela porque x 4 es
cero y bueno x 1 igual a 3 x 2 igual a
menos 2 será que ya secundó esta
igualdad tres por uno menos dos es 13
por 2 6 menos 12 43 por 39 menos 8 es 1
perfecto también se cumple y esto quiere
decir que entonces este tercer vector en
nuestro conjunto de vectores columna
tampoco aporta nada nuevo lo podemos
escribir como una combinación lineal de
los dos primeros vectores y bueno
entonces con toda esta información a que
estoy llegando
el espacio vectorial generado y esperán
es más déjeme ponerlo de esta forma éste
sí lo cruzo y aquí voy a poner que
entonces el espacio columna de la matriz
am que era igual al espacio vectorial
generado por los vectores b1 b2 b3 b4
columna a mis cuatro vectores columna de
esta matriz am y ahora podemos
prescindir de estos dos porque son
combinaciones lineales de los dos
primeros por lo tanto esto es lo mismo
que el espacio vectorial generado por
los primeros dos vectores es decir por
el vector 123 y por el vector 114 como
los otros dos son combinaciones lineales
de los dos primeros entonces el espacio
vectorial generado por estos dos
vectores es mi espacio columna de la
matriz a y aunque seguramente te estás
preguntando si estos dos vectores son
linealmente independientes es decir
habrá forma de escribir a uno de los dos
como una combinación lineal del otro y
bueno si pensamos una combinación lineal
de solamente un vector estamos pensando
en la multiplicación escalar de este
mismo vector así que habrá forma de
escribir uno de estos
como un múltiplo escalar del otro déjame
ponerlo aquí si tengo el vector 123 ya
este vector lo voy a multiplicar por una
constante una constante que multiplica
el vector 123 y esto por definición es
exactamente lo mismo que 1 por 0 2 por 0
3 por 6 habrá forma de encontrar una
constante que satisfaga que esto sea
igual al vector 1 14 es decir en mi otro
vector pues encontramos un hace que pase
esto pues ya acabamos entonces que me
poner aquí 11 4 pero entonces tenemos
que igualar componente componente y en
este caso me dice que se tiene que ser
igual a 11 por uno es igual a 1 en este
caso se tiene que valer un medio y aquí
ya hay una contradicción y es más si no
te basta en nuestra tercera componente
se tendría que valer cuatro tercios y es
otra contradicción es decir no podemos
encontrar una constante una sola que
satisfaga que al multiplicar la por el
primer vector nos dé el segundo vector y
es de igual manera para probar lo
contrario para tomarnos el segundo
vector y ver que no hay ninguna
constante tal que al multiplicarlo por
el segundo vector nos dé el primer
vector
esto quiere decir que estos dos vectores
son linealmente
dependientes y más aún que entonces el
conjunto de vectores 1 2 3 si estamos
bien 1 2 3 y 1 2 3 el conjunto de
vectores que contiene el 1 2 3 y al 11 4
es una base y ojo es una base porque son
linealmente independientes y porque
generan a todo el espacio columna de a y
bueno ya casi no tengo tiempo por lo
tanto te dejo por este vídeo y bueno lo
que voy a hacer en los siguientes vídeos
es dado que ya establece que esta es una
base del espacio columna de amd entonces
vamos a intentar visualizarlo porque
recuerda que podemos decir que el
espacio columna de amd es igual al
espacio vectorial generado por estos dos
vectores y nos vamos a dar cuenta que en
r3 el espacio vectorial generado por
estos dos vectores es un plano un plano
en r3 y bueno estoy haciendo un
pequeñísimo repaso y lo he dicho miles
de veces cuando estoy diciendo que esta
es una base estoy diciendo que estos
vectores generan el espacio vectorial de
sda y bueno estos cuatro vectores
también lo hacían pero la diferencia es
que estos dos vectores de mí
son linealmente independientes bueno de
cualquier manera te dejo ahora